tina rosenberg author of the book
children of Cain what does that mean the
book is about people in Latin America
who do violence and I chose the title in
part because of its connotations of
violence and weak art in part because of
the connotations of universality that
come with that comes with a biblical
title what is that what is the biblical
story well the story is of Cain and Abel
Cain who took a rock and slew his
brother was that a hard title to come by
it had always I'd always wanted some
form of Cain in the title I had I had
played with different forms of it
it's not about children and I think the
title may may somehow be misleading the
title is about Cain spiritual children
which is people who do evil why'd you
write the book I wrote it because I was
living in Latin America and in in my six
years there you can't get away from
violence it really does a lot to shape
how society is down there and it's
something that hits almost everyone in
society personally and I wanted to try
and explain it I had been reading news
stories about violence in Latin America
and they normally were about the victims
about grieving widows and children who
are orphaned and those stories I thought
were touching but they didn't help to
explain why that violence always exists
in Latin America this book is not about
the victims it's the perpetrators it's
about people who commit evil or people
who learn to live with evil and why they
do it before we get into some of the
details I want to quickly go through the
six countries that you were in and by
doing the way to do that I thought might
be just to read the title of the
chapters to start with Quixote titles
are somewhat enigmatic um Quixote is
about an honest judge in Medellin a man
who is assigned in 1984 a case that will
require him to indict Pablo Escobar
who's the head of the Medine cartel and
who has killed just about every previous
judge who invited who indicted him and
this judge mini gain is the second
largest city in Colombia and it's the
city where the the drug mafia has its
has its base and judge Medina decides to
indict Pablo Escobar so the story is
really about a man
Columbia who takes very seriously his
responsibilities as a citizen and
believes in his country as a nation and
the reason I chose him is because he's a
rare bird in Colombia
the country has produced a few martyrs
like him but the real character in that
chapter is the city of Medellin because
what the story is about there is how
Medellin a very modern wealthy vibrant
Latin American city that's famous for
its organ transplants and skyscrapers
has really become a medieval city in
terms of learning to live with violence
and corruption the good sailor a good
sailor is about an Argentine a man named
Alfredo Estes who is from a wealthy
educated European family very
well-traveled very genteel and
cultivated he's a member of the
Argentine Navy which considers itself to
be almost a diplomatic service the most
civilized branch of the service in a
country that considers itself an island
of civilization marooned in a whole
continent of barbarism and yet this man
was responsible during the dirty war for
the deaths of hundreds of people
dialectic dialectic is about two people
in Peru Xavier who is a young Shining
Path guerrilla a very funny sarcastic
kid who lives with his mother and
worries about getting his old girlfriend
back and one meets wants me to bring him
Reeboks from Chile and in his spare time
blows up banks and supports works in a
movement that slits policeman's throat
and really is a member of one of the
most vicious sadistic terrorist
guerrilla groups in the world laboratory
laboratory is about El Salvador it's
about the rich in El Salvador members of
the 14 families who bit of an
exaggeration but basically the 14
families who run the country title
refers to the fact that as roberto
d'aubuisson who is their political hero
says the united states was doing an
experiment on El Salvador we were
treating them like guinea pigs putting
money in and seeing if that could make
the country change in the end of the
chapter I agree with dalbi song there
was an experiment going on but I think
the experiment worked the other way
around we were seeing
not how much money we would have to give
to killers to make them stop killing but
how much the killers could the killers
were running an experiment to see how
much they could get away with before the
United States would cut off their money
and the answer was almost anything and I
think in the in the end I conclude that
the mouse also trains his scientist when
he rings the bell the doctor brings him
cheese the triumph triumph is about the
Sandinistas in Nicaragua the main
character is a man named Lewis carrion
Cruz who is a very wealthy young
Nicaraguan who went to Exeter Exeter
Academy here in the States and went to
college here and got into the Christian
movement became a sandanista in the
early 70s through the Christian movement
he believed in Marxism and worked in a
commune aquestion commune in new coreg
WA and had these grand ideals he was
against the dictator Somoza because the
dictator jailed political prisoners and
censored newspapers and and shut down
strikers and then when carry on after
the Revolution carrion became one of the
nine commandante's who was running
Nicaragua and he became Vice Minister of
the Interior and his job became
repressing political dissidents and then
he supported the jailing of strikers he
supported the censorship of newspapers
and he had very valid reasons for
wanting to do all those things from his
point of view but the point of the story
is that he turned into his worst
nightmare and and how that happened the
pig's tail pig tail is about the country
where I lived in for four years Chile
and Chile is a country that for 150
years had been in democracy with a very
strong Civic culture and prided itself
on the fact that the coos and violence
that occur in other countries in Latin
America cannot happen here in Chile then
you know che staged General Pinochet
staged to school against President
Allende in 1973 and the main character
of my story is a man named Paris who
during the IND regime with a college
student in a very socialist eye and a
supporter and after Pinochet coup he
went into hiding for a while but then
came out of hiding and found that things
were going pretty well he went into his
family's business which was selling
cheap imported clothing
he bought a new car every year he bought
himself a VCR a couple times new TV set
every year and fell asleep politically
and then when the economy crashed in
1982 and he got hit in the pocketbook he
suddenly woke up and said my god there's
been murder and torture going on here
but he hadn't thought of that
for nine years until it hit him in the
purse and the fact that that happened in
Chile to a large number of people is
very sobering the title comes from a
Garcia Marquez fable 100 years of
solitude where the buendia family has a
tendency the women have a tendency to
fall in love with their brothers and
cousins and the children that are
produced by those unions are born with
the tail of a pig and it's a really a
horrible little story about what the
human body is capable of producing and I
think that is a metaphor for what
happened in Chile this country of habeas
corpus and afternoon tea that had always
followed the rules was horrified to find
what their own body politic was capable
of producing a Pinochet you dedicate the
book to Dianna Sandler in the memory of
Phillip Sandler who is Diana Sandlin
they're my grandparents Phillip Sadler
who died in 1979 was a journalist and
when he died with city editor of the
Jewish daily forward the remaining
Yiddish newspaper in New York who is
John D and Catherine T MacArthur people
who have never met who are very
important in my life I'm a MacArthur
Fellow I want to MacArthur Fellowship
five years ago which is one of those
deals so they call you and say you don't
know us but we're going to give you some
money and you can go do whatever you
want and that's what I wanted to do did
you ever find out who those two are or
were are they are they still alive oh no
well that John D MacArthur is no longer
alive but he is the founder of the
MacArthur Foundation no they're very
famous people and that's not who called
me is your money about up yeah in April
what did you how much mind you get a
year it varied from year to year but I
think it started at 25,000 a year for
five years not too bad
was that it looking back on it was it a
good deal to be picked out of the world
of talent
what do you think yes of course it was
great it's it's it was a wonderful thing
and it also gave me the credibility I
think to be able to do this book how did
it work by the way somebody's call you
one day and say you're a MacArthur
Fellow mm-hmm and I didn't believe them
you didn't apply for no no you don't
apply they just call you but I had had a
friend in graduate school who loved to
play pranks on people and he would call
and pretend he was Jimmy Carter or other
people so I assumed that that's what
this was and it took some convincing on
the part of Kent Hope the man who called
me that that no in fact this was real
and I really had won this thing what
were you doing before this I was writing
magazine articles from Latin America and
somebody had picked it up in the
MacArthur Foundation and that was the
reason you got the five-year fella I
understand they have a system of
nominators who are secret people who
choose people with there's a whole
system of your nominated and then they
send your file around to people for
comment it's complicated and once you
get this are you supposed to do anything
with the money you can do whatever you
like who what is the Carnegie Endowment
for international peace which you also
listen right yes after coming back from
Latin America last year I have been it
writing the book at to Washington
think-tanks and one of them is the
Carnegie Endowment and now the Overseas
Development Council what are they
they're think-tanks Carnegie Endowment
is a collection of scholars who work on
international relations issues and the
overseas development council works on
third world issues is there any reason
do you have to be a certain political
bent to go to these places or they just
just walk in the door and they say oh
yeah you're a MacArthur Fellow come on
in that helps no you don't they don't
have a certain we have both places how
Democrats and Republicans where'd you
grow up
Michigan where Holt Michigan a small
town outside of Lansing how long did you
live there till I went to college where
did you go to college I went to
Northwestern and Chicago what do you
study mmm I don't recall studying
anything um I worked in political
campaigns and did a lot of theater but I
think I did get a degree in political
science and a master's in journalism
what political campaigns did you work
I worked I worked for Abner Mikva who
was the congressman from that area and
now a judge and then I worked when a
campaign from mcfuzz replacement my
candidate lost and I worked in a
campaign for a man who was elected to
the Illinois Supreme Court Seymour Simon
and what was the impetus to get into
politics in the first place my family
was very political
I was out ringing doorbells for McGovern
when I was 12 after college where'd you
go well I got that master's degree which
took a year and then I came to
Washington and lived in Washington until
1985 when I moved to Nicaragua what was
the reason to go to Nicaragua
coincidence let me before before 85 I
had no interest in Latin America I would
skip those stories when I read them in
the paper all the name sounded the same
I couldn't imagine why all those people
did those terrible things to each other
all the time
and then a friend of mine who was half
Nicaraguan asked me if I wanted to go
with a group of reporters he was
bringing and I went and and it was like
visiting the moon it was fascinating and
I decided to stay so I stayed there for
two years and then moved to Chile where
did you live I lived in a group house in
Managua a house that I shared with three
Nicaraguan women and what were the first
things that caught your attention once
you got there well I'd never been to a
poor country before and I'd never been
to a socialist country before although
wasn't very socialist um and the
quantity of foreigners in Managua was
was interesting to me the place had
really been invaded by people from every
country on Earth and and the the bizarre
character of Managua as a city it was
destroyed in the earthquake and then
destroyed also in the insurrection in
the war the Sandinistas one in the late
70s and it was never rebuilt and so it's
a city that looks like a moonscape
there's a big hotel and in three blocks
of fields with horses grazing there's I
think three working elevators in the
entire country in the country how many
people are Nicaragua three million how
many people in Managua think about a
third of them live in Managua and so
during those two years or what you do I
learned Spanish um quite well absolutely
fluently um I wrote I walked around a
lot tried to fix my car
took up about a quarter of my time
because you can't find parts I mean this
thing was held together with string and
duct tape and jar lids and just learned
about life talk to people who was the
president then Daniel Ortega what do you
think of him I never met him personally
I think that from what I know of him I
would have a lot of respect for him I
think that someone who comes to power
after being a gorilla and being in jail
for seven years as he was is not a
person who's likely to be a Democrat and
is not a person who's likely to be
prepared for governing and I don't think
he was either of those things when he
came in I think he grew in office he was
definitely one of the most pragmatic of
the Sandinistas and I think under the
circumstances in which the Sandinistas
were in power he did a creditable job
and I think the most important thing he
did was turn over power to Violeta
Chamorro when she beat him in the last
elections I think that was a decision
that was very hard for him to make and
I'm very glad he made it what's it mean
to be a saint and ISTA um well I can
tell you what I think it meant while I
was there it's a sad story
I think when that when the nicaraguan
when the revolution came in 1979 the
triumph of which the chapter speaks
there's a tremendous sense of joy that
finally the dictator was overthrown and
now the poor would have power and
everybody would be able to have beans
and rice and the United States which had
virtually controlled the country would
not be able to and for a while life
there I get the impression was really a
party it was a celebration and things
didn't work very well but nobody cared
because now you know it was it was
theirs and gradually that sense of the
Spanish word is Mystica which means this
this almost mystical passion and romance
in life and dedication to something that
got worn away as the years passed and
things didn't get better and people
realize that the demands on them were
more than ever and life got harder and
the economy got worse and people got
more and more cynical and the slogans
that people had once used seriously like
the triumph or
Nicaragua Libre free Nicaragua began to
take on an ironic tinge and I think
after a while people who had become
Sandinistas because they really believed
in in the Sandinistas type of Marxism or
they really believed in the in the
nationalism of being a sandanista were
fewer and fewer and those who became
Sandinistas because they believed in
good jobs or they believed in access to
imported products I think those became
greater and greater in number and the
revolution became somewhat cynical you
picked Luis carry on Cruz as your main
character in the triumph chapter about
Nicaragua why in part because he's
someone who knows the United States and
lived here and and I think for that
reason readers can identify with him a
little more but also in part because
here was an intelligent idealistic man
who had a career that I think mirrors in
part the decay of the revolution around
him he came in with very good intentions
and ended up committing the since he had
been protesting against and he didn't
want to but he felt justified in what he
did of course he blames he blames all of
these things on the United States if the
United States hadn't sponsored the
Contra movement then he wouldn't have
had to do all those things I don't think
that's the case I think the country's
aggravated nicaragua's problems but I
don't think they caused them and I think
part of the problem with revolution is
that is that a revolution carries the
seeds of its own destruction because all
the good things it brings have a
corollary the fact that the rich are no
longer in power means that they tend to
leave the country and unfortunately they
tend to take their money with them and
they tend to be the educated classes the
fact that food is subsidized is good
because it means that poor people can
buy it but it's bad because it means
that farmers in Nicaragua could go to
the store and buy corn and beans
more cheaply than they could plant them
and therefore they didn't plant anything
so the revolution began to starve to
death how did it is his name is his last
name cruiser carry on how did you find
mr. carrion I knocked on the door of the
ministry and there he was he what
ministry again no he started out as the
Vice foreign minister and then he became
minister of the economy ironically just
at the time when the sand
had decided that their socialist
policies weren't working and they
adopted the kind of austerity measures
that the International Monetary Fund is
imposing on Latin America the really
strange thing about it is that most
countries adopt these measures because
they're forced to as the price of
getting new loans but the Sandinistas
knew they weren't going to get any
because the United States wasn't going
to let them so here is this group of
socialists deciding that they wanted to
adopt right-wing economic policies not
because they had to but because they
thought this will work this will save
our economy so this poor guy who came in
as a Marxist protesting against
draconian capitalism he becomes in
charge of instituting the same types of
economic policies he had been protesting
against and he would call press
conferences to announce that you know
foreign investment was up and government
spending had been cut these are the
kinds of things you expect to see
Pinochet's ministers in Chile announcing
but they weren't what you expected to
hear from a sandanista I found him to be
quite serious he looks like an
accountant he is quiet almost shy not at
all well he's very timid and very
reflective with a very keen sense of
irony about his career he knows exactly
what he was doing and also finds it
somewhat ironic and is not entirely sure
now that the Revolution was worthwhile
I asked him I you know he was we were
talking about how he was saying that you
know the United States was the cause of
it and Latin American revolutions would
always be ruined by the United States so
I said well why bother then I mean if
you know this is going to happen isn't
it irresponsible to have a revolution in
the first place in part I was just
trying to provoke him but he didn't take
it that way he said he said well maybe
you have a point in some countries I
think you have to exhaust the
possibilities of what you can do through
reform before you have a revolution but
in some countries it's just going to be
inevitable anyway to the crowner and the
story about Luis carrion is that he's
probably this month starting his studies
at Harvard's JFK School of Government
economics where had he gone to school
before in the United States he'd gone to
Exeter High School and then went to
Rensselaer Polytechnic and finished up
at I don't think he finished college but
he also studied at the National
University
managua how many of the Senate Senate
nice to leadership had gone to school
here here main I staged many he's the
only one he's the only yeah and he was I
think he by having a few years of
college made him the most educated
sandanista most of these people were
guerrillas they were not students did
you change your feeling about what the
problems were in Nicaragua from the time
you showed up till the time you left
sure I came in I came into a Managua
that was basically a movie set and it
was filled with other people like me who
were either the journalists for example
I'm thinking of one guy who was a
photographer who could he seemed to live
on ramen cigarettes and he would trek
through the mountains with the army for
a week and come out with a great tan and
next week's cover for Newsweek or time
or Sandinistas as they were called the
international visitors who came in to
support the revolution by picking coffee
or teaching soil management everybody
was there starring in their own personal
drama and I think I had fallen into that
and I was I was really a supporter of
the Sandinistas when I got there and
gradually the revolution became real for
me and I started to understand some of
the problems involved in a revolution
even one staff by people who were
pragmatic and serious like I think
Louise carry on is and I left thinking
it didn't work here and that's partially
the fault of the United States but not
entirely and I'm not sure it work
anywhere if it didn't work here what's
at the you know at the core of why there
was a revolution in the first place what
was getting at the people um
decades of Somoza dictatorship a dynasty
really the father the brother then
Anastasio Somoza
he was not very violent as dictators go
but he was very corrupt and Nicaraguans
felt that their country didn't belong to
them they felt it belonged to the United
States what do you think of Violeta
Chamorro well um what do I think of her
she's a symbol the person running the
government is her son-in-law
Antonio Lucca who I think is a decent
guy and very small
but I will refer to the words of Enrique
Bal annuls he is a Nicaraguan
businessman and very very anti
sandanista and when mrs. Chamorro was
nominated the Santa Anita newspaper
asked Melania if he thought she was
qualified to be President and he said of
course she's qualified she's Nicaraguan
and she's over 25 years old that's what
I think of her to him what was the last
time you were there right before the
election and what's the change between
1985 when your first went there and now
well I haven't been there since mrs.
Chamorro took over so I can't speak to
that but from when from 1985 to when I
left or the last time I was there just a
tremendous weariness before the rich
were trying to get out by the time I
left it was the poor who were trying to
get out people were getting poor every
week the war was really terrible the war
just took a tremendous tremendous toll
on people will that country make it
without another revolution or without
another major change I don't know if
it'll make it with or without another
revolution I'm one of the theses of the
book is that the countries that had
always done well in Latin America the
ones that had the good fortune to be
poor at the time of the colonization and
therefore had nothing to offer the
Spanish like Costa Rica like Costa Rica
like Chile which had basically no
Indians and no good minerals so the
Spanish did not do their customary job
of raping and pillaging they didn't set
up societies of master and slave the
conquerors went to Chile and saw nothing
they were interested in and turned
around a whim Peck up to Peru and that
is one big reason why Chile was always a
successful country and Peru was never a
successful country and Peru has really
apartheid like class differences it's
the countries like Chile in Costa Rica
which always did well which I really
think are always going to do well and
the countries that started out with this
handicap like Peru and like Nicaragua
that are going to have tremendous
trouble learning to overcome their past
and I'm just not sure how it can be done
it can be done because you're up did it
Europe in the 1600s you'd never have
thought that Europe would ever turn out
to be a continent of democracies but it
it did and I'm sure that can happen in
Latin America you spent much time in
other parts of the world besides it's
not practically none sitting in
Washington thinking about Latin and
South America what comes to your head
right now you want to get on a plane and
go down there sure no I have a
tremendous nostalgia I really miss the
place where would you go if you had one
spot you had to pick out to lever to
visit either one both maybe um I love
puru puru right now suffering from all
10 biblical plagues at once
terrorism cholera and garbage in the
streets draught tremendous economic
collapse cocaine with all its problems
it's a fascinating country and there are
wonderful people there and I find it
very compelling I also have a soft spot
for Chile
I love Chile I lived there for four
years why did you leave Nicaragua
um what year did you leave I fell in
love with Chile in 87 I moved to to
Chile to live what did you find there
Chile is a very serious country people I
belonged to a salsa club in Chile and
people go to dance salsa wearing black
tights and serious expressions on their
faces
what salsa salsa is is a dance music
Latin Latin dance music that's usually
done with bright colors and happy
expressions and Chile very somber Chile
is a serious country the country of
habeas corpus and afternoon tea where
people follow the rules um and I can't
explain the chemical attraction I feel
for Chile I just got off the plane and
felt this is my home how big is it 12 or
13 million people small tiny and where
did you live what city I lived in
Santiago but the city I love is
Valparaiso which is the port city and it
looks like San Francisco might have
looked 200 years ago it's all hilly with
wooden trains carrying people to their
homes up the sides of the hills fishing
boats seagulls it's beautiful biggest
city in the country its Santiago nutball
petting zoo
the capital is the biggest city and what
about your story in the book what did
you find there that most intrigued you
um well as I said it was this process
through which people who have had a
democratic history learned to fall
asleep
under Pinochet I'll tell you one story
that I thought really was by the way
before you do this story who was
Pinochet General Pinochet
was the Chile Chilean army general who
staged a coup in 1973 and overthrew
Salvador Allende who was the elected
president a Marxist first time I believe
a Marxist had ever been elected to
office in the world and his
administration ran for three years and
was characterized at the end with with
tremendous chaos helped in great measure
by the United States which tried to
economically sabotage IND but also just
tremendous chaos in that its economic
policies were not workable and Pinochet
staged a very bloody coup in which
probably 2,000 people were killed in
that in the coup and in the years
immediately afterwards and most Chileans
supported some sort of army intervention
in part ironically because of the
democratic history they felt it can't
happen here our military isn't like the
other militaries it never had been and
our military will come in and restore
order and clean house for six months and
then leave seventeen years later the
military left after after you know
carrying on one of the most brutal and
repressive regimes in latin america and
becoming a symbol of state terrorism and
it intrigued me that a country learned
to live with that the story is the
following it was told to me by a man
named Orlando science who was one of
Pinochet's first economic ministers he
was a businessman and a big opponent of
ien day came in was working for Pinochet
but quit the government in 1974 because
he didn't like what Pinochet was doing
with human rights violations so I met
him in 1986 and he told me that a friend
of his who had been Pinochet is press
attache at the United Nations came back
to Chile on vacation and saw an
interview that that Orlando science had
given to an opposition magazine in which
he criticized the human rights
violations of the Pinochet government
and the woman said to him Orlando you
know I knew you were against this
government but you've been duped these
human rights violations didn't exist the
molested them up I certainly don't know
anybody personally who was who was
tortured or who
what was was killed and he says to her I
know someone when I was in the
government my girlfriend came to me and
said they've taken my sister-in-law away
please help me find her and he said to
her and I pulled all the strings I had
and finally I located the sister-in-law
and I arranged for my girlfriend to be
able to visit and it was a tremendously
emotional experience for my girlfriend
to see the sister-in-law who had been
beaten and had been tortured and he's
telling the story to the woman and she
starts to turn pale and starts to cry
and he says to her and I'm surprised you
don't remember because it had been her
she had been his girlfriend and had been
her sister-in-law who was taken and she
said to him she was crying and she said
to him would you believe me if I if I
tell you that I forgot these years have
been very good to me and I'm a very
appreciative person and part of my
appreciation
is forgetting that this happened and I
asked him if he believed her and he said
yes he thought he did because this
happened to me to many many people in
Chile why because things went well for
them under Pinochet the economy was
growing there was a boom and after the
total politicization and the chaos of
the IND years people wanted to get to
not think about politics they wanted to
go back to working in their gardens and
running their businesses and making
money they were exhausted and the
government punished you if you were
political if you were just a good
citizen in you and you didn't do
anything political then you could carry
on in peace and you wouldn't have to
worry about the government bothering you
if you did any sort of political or
union activity then you got it but and
think so people retreated to their
private lives and they prospered the sky
Paris that I write about he did quite
well he did better than he ever thought
was possible and the stores were filled
with imported products and whiskey and
consumer goods and people didn't see
what they didn't want to see which of
the countries and how he focused on six
would you not care to go back to for any
great length of time
um well it's very difficult to live in
Peru I mean I'd love to go back there
and live but I think life would be very
hard and the levels of violence and
poverty now have gotten to the point
where people are very psychologically
affected and they become aggressive in
their daily lives it will be hard to
live in Peru
I mean people live in Peru um 22 million
and I think 7 a million of those are in
Lima and how did a man of Japanese
descent get elected as president he got
elected because Peruvians are becoming
more and more cynical about their
traditional political leaders and it's
gotten to the point where that they
don't just throw out the party in power
they throw out the whole system in power
right before the elections it looked
like Mario Vargas Llosa who's a
world-famous novelist was going to win
and part of the reason that people liked
him there were two main reasons one was
that he was a political outsider he
wasn't a politician and he wasn't from a
traditional party and the second reason
is they thought this guy's got good
connections he's European looking he's
white he has all these important friends
people will write checks people will
will come to Peru's aid
well Vargas Llosa then began to
associate with a traditional right-wing
parties in Peru and people started
looking at him as just one other
politician and then they saw this
Japanese guy and they figured he's
Japanese his connections are even better
than Vargas Josas you know Japan this
prosperous rich country and fujimori
started his campaign started circulating
rumors that Japan would pay Peru's
national debt which the Japanese embassy
denied but people believed anyway and
once Vargas she also became just another
politician Fujimori then became this
shining samurai on the white horse who
would come in to save Peru and he won in
a landslide
when you're living in Latin and Central
America and you look at the United
States what do you see um well it's an
interesting question what do I see did
you and did you change your thinking
about this place the longer you were
down there yes one of the things that's
interested me is after living in the
third world one of the overwhelming
qualities of the third world is a
division there's one set of institutions
such as school
hospitals and neighborhoods for the rich
and one set for the rest and it's as if
the two don't live in the same country
the United States looks more and more
like that to me and I don't know whether
it really changed while I was away or I
just see it in a different way now if
you were if somebody said come to the
State Department went before you went to
Latin America in 1985 and helped us run
our Latin American effort and they set
it to you now how would you have changed
your opinion over those years I don't
know what I would have said back then
because I didn't know anything back then
I I had she felt though didn't yeah but
I hadn't I hadn't thought about it and I
really hadn't really I hadn't heard of
most of these countries now what I would
say is I think one important thing these
countries need and enable to be able to
overcome their history is a sense that
everybody there lives in the same
country in the sense that of everybody
pulling up to the table and saying we
share this country let's agree on some
rules that we can all abide by because
what you have characterizing countries
like El Salvador in Peru is the elites
who refuse to give up even one
millimeter of their privileges in
exchange for social peace I mean the
concept that one has to make compromises
the one shares a country with others
seems to be missing in a lot of these
places and you had up until recently
actually in Peru and you still do with
the guerrillas very hard militant left
that also did not want to make any
compromises and didn't and these two
groups were so polarized that there was
really no way that they could share a
country without resorting to violence I
think when one world the United States
can play and I don't want to
overestimate the power of the United
States has this is a problem that Latins
will have to solve but I think the u.s.
has a tremendous influence over the
elites with the fall of Leninism and and
increasing disbelief in Marxism you now
have a left that's more willing to
compromise and poses less of a threat to
the traditional elites and I think one
thing the United States could do would
be to say to Latin militaries and Latin
business elites be good citizens make
compromises you live and you have to
share your society with others we could
say to the military we will no longer
support a military that commits human
rights violations and right now in Peru
and Colombia you have the two worst
human rights violators in the continent
very very brutal militaries which which
have ingrained culture of killing of
killing innocent civilians we should
tell them you will you will not get a
penny from us in that case we should
tell the elites we will not support you
unless you tolerate labor unions unless
you pay people what their work is worth
unless you pay your taxes and recognize
that you have responsibility for your
government in other words these
countries are not countries of citizens
their countries of inhabitants and what
Latin America needs to do is learn that
citizenship implies this is my
government I will abide by its rules and
I am responsible also for what happens
here and I think one thing the United
States should do with its foreign policy
is encourage that process what do you
think about writing books or writing a
book was it interesting I loved doing it
the process of working on it of talking
to people of traveling is a wonderful
thing you can go wherever you like and
call on anyone you want and ask them any
impudent question you want I can't think
of a better job than that why did you
pick Morrow as your publisher um I had
the choice of two publishers who were
very interested in me and one publisher
sat down with me and said we're going to
make you a star and the other publisher
Morrow sat down with me and said we're
going to help you write the best book
that you can write and I chose them what
did they mean by making you a star and
what would you have had to have done
differently I imagined the book this
book is is a book that it's very
intriguing to me and I and I believe is
a serious book that explores why people
commit violence not just in Latin
America but but why you I feel that
these people are violent not because
they're Latin but because they're human
and the book has a lot of that in it but
it's not a glitzy book it doesn't have a
lot of famous people in it and I think
that had I gone with the other publisher
and tried to write a more commercial
book it would not have been as
interesting were there other countries
you could have put in this book you got
six in this one sure where there are
others and who would which countries
would they have been well the problem in
El Salvador is very similar to the
problem
Guatemala the control of the country the
stranglehold that the oligarchy has it's
probably worse in Guatemala than it is
in El Salvador I could have written
about Guatemala I could have written
about Mexico which has tremendous
repression and tremendous human rights
violations and doesn't tend to get
talked about in the United States why do
we spend so little time and maybe I'm
prejudicing your answer by sivan
suggestion is on the South American
Latin American problem other than when
we had the spotlight on Nicaraguan El
Salvador what is it about this country
that were well just by that much time on
a friend of mine said in terms of the
u.s. press there are no Latin stories
there's just us stories and Latin
settings and I think that's true for how
the United States tends to think about
Latin America we're interested in the
United States problems which are drugs
which is why we want to know what's
going on in Colombia when we were
fighting a war in Nicaragua we were
eager for news in El Salvador we're
interested because we put so much money
into that country's war but we don't
tend to think about the rest and I think
one reason is because we don't tend to
think that those are people like us but
they are one thing that I marveled at
for example I went to Medellin which is
the capital of the drug mafia and the
most violent city in the world not
involved in a war and the single leading
cause of death in Medellin is multiple
gunshot wounds and people have learned
to live with that level of violence
they've learned to think about it in the
passive voice as if it's a weather
condition that just sort of arrives and
doesn't have any perpetrator and I was
thinking how is it that people learn to
it to think about violence that way and
on my 10th day in Medellin
I met a man who was an ex-policeman and
we were talking and he said to me Tina
tomorrow I'm meeting with a friend of
mine a man named say sorry who wants to
kill his father his father's a bad man
and treats the family very badly and he
so he's hiring two hitmen to kill his
father and I'm setting up this deal do
you want to come along okay I said yeah
I'd love to so they all came to my hotel
and we all went up on the rooftop
restaurant and had a cup of coffee and
it was me in this cop this ex-cop and se
saw in these two teenage [ __ ] hitmen and
I interviewed them about what their
profession is and how they work and how
much they get paid and how they think
about it and how
their family thinks about it and then
they interviewed say sorry what time
does your father come home from work
what is his usual route this is he armed
does he have bodyguards does he have a
godfather in the neighborhood and then
we said our good-byes and the next day
it occurred to me that I had witnessed a
murder being planned and I hadn't
thought about it I hadn't made the
connection in my mind between the fact
that say sighs father was going to die
and these two young kids who were going
to kill him in ten days in Medellin I
learned to think like they do about
violence in Chile some of the people I
met who were the most sophisticated the
most civilized the most the closest to
my approximation of sophisticated people
in the United States you know fluent in
English and French and people who loved
opera
they were Pinochet's biggest supporters
and they were people who had who
justified and supported the violence of
the Pinochet government more than more
than anyone else it is people like us
who commit violence in Latin America and
Americans like me down there learn to
think like those people in a very short
period of time and I believe that if
more Americans realize that about Latin
America we would be more interested in
it because it is in many ways not a
separate race of people they're human
beings and they think like human beings
and they think like we do in a lot of
ways was it is it Judge Medina mm-hmm
who went after mr. Escobar and Colombia
Madine my on the right track here I just
want to ask you about one little
incident was it when the judge was
killed was it was it his nine-year-old
son that saw the that's regular hiding
behind the tree tell that story um tell
the whole story I mean I jumped it okay
well my main character in Colombia is
this judge who is an idealist is a man
who in 1984 was assigned the case that
would require him to indict Pablo
Escobar the head of the medellin
traffickers and he could have done with
what most judges did before him which is
to throw the case out
and therefore he could have gotten rich
and lived a very long life instead he
chose to indict Pablo Escobar knowing
that that was bringing a death sentence
on his head and for a solid year he got
death threats he got phone calls saying
judge Medina we know your children's
route home from school you know they
would recite to him passages of his
legal opinions um and he was finally
killed a year later and his son who was
nine witnessed the killing it was done
with with by in his front yard as his
wife was bringing him home from work one
day and now his his wife when I met her
is a lawyer who now wants to become a
judge and is interested in taking up a
similar line of work by the way what
does Quixote mean you know two refers to
Don Quixote which is the the famous
Spanish character of the man tilting at
windmills the idea lists the ultimate
idealist which was judgment in his
favorite book you have another book in
mind next um I would like to do another
book you know about I don't know yet are
you through writing about Latin America
I don't know um I am still very
fascinated by by Latin America I still
find it a country where the noises are
louder and the colors are brighter and
and and life is more vivid and intense
and the stories are better and all the
decisions in people's daily lives are
much more life or death than up here
it's still a fascinating place when you
come back up here to the United States
in Washington do you find many people
knowing much about that part of the
world in DC yes in general not so much
in general people's experience with it
is like is like mine was before I went
they skip the stories in the newspaper
the name sound the same you wonder why
they're so violent down there on the
back of your jacket here you have
congratulatory positive statements
written about your book from Greg
Easterbrook contributing editor of
Newsweek James Fallows author Atlantic
Monthly you also have mr. area mister
near re and I are from Human Rights
Watch yeah and also Robert pastor former
director of Latin Affairs National
Security Council how's that
the publishing house sends the
manuscript to various readers beforehand
and asks them for their comment does it
sell books they are under the impression
that it does why because people pick it
up and lecture you know that somebody
famous who you respect thinks this is a
good book so you're more inclined to buy
it especially for an author like me
where it's my first book and and if you
haven't heard of the author it helps to
have famous people plugging in on the
back does it ever work for you when you
go buying books probably it has sure
yeah El Salvador how much money a year
does the United States give in foreign
aid to El Salvador well I think at the
end of the 80s we were giving them
actually more money we were making up
more than half of their federal budget
we were putting in more money than they
were to their federal coffers I think
over the 10 years we gave them a total
of four billion dollars and that's for a
country where there are only 5 million
people so that's that's a tremendous
amount of money top 5 of the American
country countries that America gives
foreign aid to why it was an experiment
we were trying to to see if
counterinsurgency could work and at a
country that was tiny and small and
supposedly easy to maneuver in and we
thought we were going to get in and get
out and it was going to be simple and it
wasn't and after 10 years the war looks
not very different than it did in 1980
except for the fact that 70,000 people
have been killed and 1/2 not 1/5 of the
countries in exile and another 10th live
in refugee camps how much time you spend
there I think I probably made about six
or seven visits over the course of
several years where'd you go it's not a
big place it's the size of Massachusetts
so I think I probably covered most of
the country would you meet um well I I
was looking for rich people so I spend
my time going to aerobics classes I hung
out at Fitness World in San Salvador
which is very much like a fitness studio
in the United States with Garfield
posters on the wall and when one of the
members had a birthday we would sing
happy birthday in English to them and we
did our aerobics to Michael Jackson
records I went to pool parties I went to
discos that's not the experience I had
in most other countries but I was
deliberately trying to meet the rich and
I'll Salvador so I had quite a different
experience here than I did most other
places how did you do that um how did I
meet them yeah I mean you just show up
knock on their door and they know that
wasn't that wouldn't have worked the
original sorta don't love American
journalists they really felt that
American journalists were not writing
the truth and they used the word with
almost a capital T in El Salvador they
felt we were supporting communist forces
there and they were very reluctant to be
interviewed I met a group of people at a
rally for Christiani
who is the president of El Salvador now
and they call themselves the Qaddafi
gang the word comes from a Spanish
sentence quatre fin de semana no
sandwich camels every weekend we get
drunk and the first two words Caliph in
our sort of like Qaddafi so they call
themselves the Qaddafi gang and it was
eight women all of them in their 30s I
think all of them divorced all of them
blonde and very very wealthy and various
of their male friends and they met every
weekend and I met these people at a
rally and they invited me to some of
their parties so I got to hang out with
them and start to understand how they
live and how they think they know what
you were doing they knew that I was
writing about their country and that I
was eager to talk to the wealthy um yeah
I think it what I was doing
did you have any ground rules um yes the
main character that I ended up writing
about did not want his name used so I
have changed his name as I indicated in
the book his name in the book is his
name in the book is Roberto Cotter and
why did he want his name changed for the
out um he wanted his his name changed
because he felt he wouldn't like what I
was writing which I that's not his name
in the book wasn't what's his name in
the book oh I haven't underlying here
somewhere I'll try to find it going back
to the Elser about trying I think it's
l-tron yes
Kara that's the name of a Peruvian I
think I interviewed so when you got
inside the group what was the first
thing you started to see oh how they
live these palatial
mansions with filled with pre-columbian
art and multiple swimming pools I will
never forget a pool party I went to at a
beach house of one of the members where
we just sat in the pool and their maid
served us platter after platter of
shrimp and crabs and and clams and
different kinds of seafood the most
luxurious spread and when we our hands
got dirty all we did was dictum in the
pool it was it's the most luxurious
existence you can possibly imagine and
another thing that I noticed was they
live behind such incredibly high walls I
mean literally and figuratively they all
their houses are rimmed with 15 foot
high brick walls within barbed wire and
then electrical wire above them in fact
in some cases when these when the power
goes out in San Salvador which is quite
frequently they can't leave their house
because their Dera doors are open and
shut through electric electric eyes so
literally they're prisoners in their in
their own in their own houses
but these people live their lives in a
few neighborhoods and they have no
contact with the rest of their country
and really no sense they live in the
rest of their country and their own
isolation makes them it is an intimate
connection with the rest of sense with
the rest of El Salvador because it's the
way they live that in part has caused
the misery going on in the rest of the
country where they get their money the
rich they get it largely from coffee or
cotton how much of the foreign aid money
from the United States goes to the rich
well back in the last days of the Reagan
administration we had a I D the Agency
for International Development had a
policy of trying to work with the elite
in El Salvador to get them to open up to
think a little differently so we
supported groups like the Chamber of
Commerce or the National Association for
private enterprise in the hopes of
trying to change these people in fact we
didn't change them they changed us would
you think of the American Embassy in El
Salvador I felt it was extraordinarily
misguided they were trying to run this
laboratory experiment by which we would
bribe these people into changing their
views
and their job was to convince Salvador
and convince the US Congress and
convince visiting reporters like me that
this was working when in fact what they
were doing was seeing how much money you
know how how much they could get away
with before we would cut their money off
and the answer is they could get away
with almost anything before we would cut
their money off in a place like El
Salvador do you find yourself getting so
attached to the individuals that you
started to lose sight of what you were
there for I didn't like the ladies
people in El Salvador much it was really
one of the few places where I had no
sympathy whatsoever for the people I was
hanging out with that was true in most
of the other places but not there and
how long did you hang out with him oh
really over repeated visits I couldn't I
couldn't put a time figure on it they
ever tried to befriend you as a friend
instead of as a reporter um not those
people no in other countries that
happened but not there you write about
mr. Dobie song who is he Roberto Dobie
son is the founder of the arena party
the right wing party in El Salvador he's
a man who is really the ideological
inspiration and in some ways the
operational chief of many of the death
squads in El Salvador he is a very
charismatic intelligent handsome man the
country's most popular politician he's
ill now I believe he's dying of cancer
now but he was he's a mesmerizing
speaker and a very evil man why didn't
he get elected he did get elected he
probably won the elections in 1984 the
US government decided that Congress
would not keep funding this war with a
man like Dobie son in power I mean why
didn't he get why didn't he run again so
we pulled some strings and instead got
Duarte in office um he didn't run again
because I think he realized that the US
wouldn't tolerate it so instead the
arena party put up Chris Gianni which
who was educated at Georgetown
University and a much more culture and
much calmer much more moderate face for
the party than Doby son what's going to
happen to up to El Salvador it um I
don't know it's possible that the war
might end I think the fall of communism
in the world has has caused guerrillas
to have second thoughts although I don't
know if that's going to change at all
any of El Salvador's
men to social problems that were behind
the war in the first place I don't think
that people like the Qaddafi gang are
going to be giving up any of their
privileges in order to to get social
peace in that country you write a lot
about torture where did you see the
worst um well I don't think anyone has
ever raised it to an art form like the
Argentine's did during the dirty war
what's the dirty dirty war in the 1970s
was a war carried out by a military
government that Argentines called they
called it el proceso in the process
which is also the Spanish word for
Kafka's novel the trial and very
appropriately so it was a regime that
was fighting a guerrilla group called
the Montoneros which was a very small
guerrilla group that had by the time the
military regime took over not much
support anymore but the military
government used it as an excuse to wipe
out the entire left in Argentina they
disappeared they are the people who are
responsible for getting the word
disappeared into the world's vocabulary
now you can disappear someone before the
Argentine's things disappeared but there
was nobody perpetrating the act now now
it's become a transitive verb they
disappeared probably nine or ten
thousand people the before disappearing
them subjecting them to unimaginable
tortures and then they would simply
vanish give us an example of an
unimaginable torture for example the
book that collected stories of these
people after the military regime left
office talked of a woman who bit off her
own tongue from the pain talked of
people who were forced to sit on the
ground in the same position for six
months never speaking um and many other
things that we never moving never
speaking never lifting their eyes to eat
yes they were fed living their own waste
I I think so
then and a lot of other physical
tortures involving electricity or
beatings or water that I don't think we
really want to get into here
this is what the book looks like it's
called children of Cain and the violence
and the violence in Latin America is a
subtitle and the author has been our
guest
Tina Rosenberg thank you very much for
joining us thank you it was a pleasure